In the meantime, I
'm sorry, I haven't
studied enough,
and it's the first time
I've heard of pain relief that night.
The main character, the grandson of the principal of the school, is care and the
number of students enrolled in a girls' school
.
You know, I
mean, Wu Cheng-chun is a human sex slave who doesn't like the school system,
or
aa, I can't take
it.
I'll get in,
but I'll invest anywhere I'm ignorant of games, so
I can't keep up with the pre-war story
Ogre-kun
aslave
I wonder if there really is a game with that kind of content
Haa
, if someone from the warehouse has a face, how long has anyone asked,
much less Nape?  But
are you serious?
Yes, I'm
usually alone, so I don't understand this kind of
vibe.